[Música]
2022 un año difícil pero no para las
empresas de lujo que siguen obteniendo
enormes beneficios 2022 iniciativas
bonitas incluso muy bonitas como esta
colaboración entre la casa rompa el
guccié y Uriel pero otras cosas más que
desastrosas empecemos por lo que molesta
[Música]
el escándalo valenciaga presenta a niños
que llevan peluches con arneses al
estilo sm se le acusa de promover la
pornografía infantil
balenciaga de nuevo con un desfile que
tuvo lugar en una montaña de barro
marcado por la presencia del muy
controvertido kanye West que desató la
indignación y la ira por una serie de
tuits antisemitas
pero valenciaga que empezó bien el año
rindiendo homenaje a los ucranianos con
una escenografía singular los maniquíes
luchan contra las ráfagas de nieve
arrastrando lo que parecen bolsas de
basura de magdalia director creativo de
la marca ha vivido la experiencia huyó
de su Georgia natal en 1993 durante la
Guerra Civil respaldada por el remín
periodistas clientes compradores están
cómodamente sentados detrás de un
cristal como símbolo de una protección
ilusoria en 2022 la guerra ruso
ucraniana está en la mente de todos el
mundo de la moda no puede fingir que no
existe la semana de la moda de Berlín
rinde homenaje al diseñador ucraniano
gris
no morir no me asusta
[Música]
porque realmente creo que la muerte no
es el final
like y si Dios dice que mi vida es estar
aquí
[Música]
o ir a luchar entonces iré a luchar
la semana de la moda de túnez acoge en
una escenografía alucinante a la
estilista ucraniana Cristina lapso
[Música]
la capital de la moda rinde homenaje a
la diseñadora ucraniana Lilia
gran parte de mi familia está hoy
conmigo mi hija mi madre mi héroe
mi marido que es un oficial del ejército
[Música]
fue herido
ahora se está recuperando
y hoy nos está apoyando
la casa Yo no se queda atrás María
gracia churi delega la decoración al
artista multidisciplinar ucraniana
pensamos que teníamos que hacer algo
optimistad
pero fue una buena decisión celebrar la
vida y no el resto
la escasez y las dificultades de
abastecimiento pusieron patas arriba la
de las Industrias textiles pero la moda
tiene la increíble capacidad de
recuperarse en tiempos de crisis desde
hace varias décadas una gran corriente
de opinión a concientizado a todo el
mundo que es un negocio sucio que
contamina debemos salvar al planeta
cambiar los métodos de producción en una
palabra debemos reciclarnos
Todos los estilos que se ven en naranja
azul rosa con algún tipo de estampado
negro todos esos eran toallas que
cogíamos y convertíamos en ropa así que
cuando hace calor como en este caso uno
puede secarse es práctico también hubo
pañoletas de seda convertidas en
vestidos Asimismo se reciclaron todos
los Blue Jeans son Blue Jeans viejos que
ya no se usan que recuperamos para hacer
unos nuevos Así que la idea es recuperar
regenerar tomar lo que hay transformarlo
y utilizar la creatividad que tenemos
para cambiar el mundo del mañana un
mundo del mañana donde ya se mezclan dos
tipos de realidad real y la virtual en
el campus del instituto francés de la
moda de París los estudiantes trabajan
en un nuevo programa
hoy escaneamos las siluetas de 43
diseñadores
seleccionamos una silueta por colección
y hacemos escaneos fotogeométricos de
150 a 180 imágenes y esto crea una
escultura
para ellos todo este mundo virtual
ofrece nuevas perspectivas y
posibilidades creativas Así que no hay
separación hay una especie de fluidez y
lo que queríamos Mostrar sobre todo con
los accesorios con los
accesorios es que los límites de la
creatividad podían llevarse aún más
lejos y sobrepasarse si los poníamos al
servicio y apoyo de una tecnología que
nos permitía crear objetos para este
nuevo mundo virtual llamado metaverso
[Música]
entonces este nuevo mundo infierno o
cielo
tal vez para algunos sea un paraíso
artificial pero hoy Lo cierto es que se
impone como un paraíso muy real para
todas las empresas que invierten sumas
colosales de dinero con el riesgo de que
allí se encuentra la lógica que ya
encontramos en las redes sociales que es
una lógica que encierra a cada persona
en su propia burbuja Así que hay mucha
esperanza hay mucha preocupación ya
veremos qué pasa
en 2023 seguirá siendo la moda un sueño
[Música]
[Aplausos]